dr. doom comes from an alternate reality
in the multiverse and in which there are
no Avengers and then eventually you're
scared of that nerdy kid that learned
how to make nuclear warheads and you're
like oh we should not been making fun of
that guy dr. doom is gonna come out of
the quantum rounds you stole my story
goo termen and now your reality is do
you stole my story new rock stars this
is row Cleary and doctor dooms MCU debut
is overdue we're going rogue practicing
social distancing with metal face masks
post you on that yeah we're good I'm
Victor Von Voss going rogue remotely
with me today our marina Mastro's ee hi
welcome back Tommy back tol hello
bittersweet farewell to my mom's bedroom
where I've been recording for the last
three months and heading back to
California next weekend it's really
gonna be hard to say goodbye to all the
memories I've made it it's not weird
don't edit any of this out leave this
all that was worth it I still use that
as a head shot just through to the
podcast listeners there our friend Joe
Vinick HR opens our welcome back to the
show my friend life to be here fully
squeezed baby alright let's get into
this guy's Doctor Doom is one of the
best villains in the Marvel lore sadly
he has toughened done justice and it's
past film iterations however I think we
can all agree the groundwork has already
been laid for his entrance to Marvel
phase 4 in all kinds of interesting ways
that may be hiding in plain sight so I
asked my panel how will Doctor Doom be
introduced to the MCU
I'm ready to jump in so Eric you have
pointed out on a couple of videos that
there is what could be considered a
little city in the back of the quantum
realm right like we've analyzed it and I
think Doctor Doom is gonna come out of
the quantum realm so if we think back
pain Reid wanted to do like a throwback
era movie in the 60s right so what if he
gets to do that now cuz he's doing it
man 3 so what if he gets to go back in
time and say like you know what the
Fantastic Four did exist they were in
the 60s and Victor Von Doom was back
there doing science doing magic which is
just science that we don't understand
yet it's so true and so he gets to have
that throwback to and film stuff as if
it's in the sixties and he gets to show
the Fantastic Four beating Von Doom and
he they think that they've defeated him
but really he just went to the quantum
realm to hide and he built that city
he's he's the lord of the quantum realm
little city that you pointed out and we
see him in ant-man 3 and the reason I
want to say this is because I think
Janet's hood in ant-man and the wasp you
we don't know who she is right when we
have that reveal that it's her at first
um what's-his-name is like afraid of his
wife like he doesn't know it's her it's
a hooded figure and that is like an
homage a visual homage to dooms hood
which you know it doesn't pay off in
that movie but it will pay off in 3 so
he pops out he's figured out how to pop
out of the quantum realm boom we have
our villain it's a rat goes over the
control panel and doom comes back all
hooded figures in the MCU or musta -
yeah the Red Skull he's like I didn't
realize that's what this is I love this
theory it answers a lot of questions
Tommy and I have asked about the quantum
realm that have not been explained and I
think that is by far the most
interesting direction they could take
for that quantum realm city because that
is what happened in the calm
they thought they got rid of Victor Von
Doom really he's just hanging out in my
core a world kicking it back with a
lizard-men of talk and now it's time
that we see those lizard men with who
would you want to play von the Victor
Von Doom marina
oh god how about because he's in it but
because he's on Twitter right now in the
news Ron Perelman yeah he's not a
scientist like he does not like
translate just wrestling also shrunken
GOP congressmen okay my friends I will
be doing scoring differently this
episode I believe Zack has been letting
off panelists too easily so instead of
awarding you points you will all begin
with ten Sparkle bucks oh gosh mark
already earned them for being just
amazing people you can consider it your
universal basic income because we give
that a try now for every gripe I have
with your theory I will just once why
does this feel worse yeah yes that's
right this is now of punishment so this
is like a negative debt sort of economy
right now or we're interesting it's like
golf right yeah how golf works you're
yeah there's money with every stroke
they miss yeah and every smoker book I
take away I you need to incinerate
whatever thing you had on here and so oh
no
marina you began with a ten sparkle boat
and I really really like your theory so
I will only deduct one just on the
argument that I think the hooded
argument is very interesting it might be
a two bit of a stretch just a bit a bit
of a stretch okay stretch if you want to
see me
or just pretend like you did no no this
is gonna happen wait oh my god I got
there we go
why do you fire in a house one of my a
with you you we usually turn the rogue
ease into something it was a box of
matches so now I'm just gonna set fire
every time you take a point Oh burns so
your your Rogi would have turned into
the sulfur match head now we get to see
fire guys
fire good all right who's next I'll go
next cuz I'm sure joven shires got a
electric theory that I do not I I prefer
to go first let's see here I first of
all shout out to Julian McMahon who I
thought was a great Doctor Doom and did
what he could with what was not really a
huge showcase for him as an actor but
really great on nip/tuck and then he was
on runaways another Marvel show that I
quite enjoyed him on anyway I think not
having Doctor Doom in the in the MCU so
far has been madness and I'm talking
about a multiverse of madness because
this is absolutely insane and I think
that most of the legends of Marvel
Comics that have not been introduced are
gonna have to be introduced through the
multiverse because otherwise the first
thing asked no matter what is gonna be
what why weren't you helping to defeat
Thanos you know so they're either gonna
have to be they're gonna have to have
origin stories after the Year 2023 or
they're gonna have to come from a
different yeah
reality yeah I think because fans are
just too crazy they'll just pick it
apart in like you know they're almost
saving fans from themselves if they do
it that way because they can actually
enjoy the movie then rather than being
like it held up in the first act for me
because why why was it Wolverine helping
them win that why didn't Wolverines rake
his gorgeous claws down Thanos his base
and stop this whole thing so anyway
my theory is Doctor Doom comes from an
alternate reality in the multiverse in
which there are no Avengers so he's this
he comes from another world where the
Avengers don't exist they never assemble
there's no they don't
disassembled they just need to not be
there so guter man from spider-man far
from home writes the script for Mysterio
that has him as this hero of another
another multiverse another world where
he is you know he's basically the the
Earth's Savior in that world that's
actually stolen from dr. Doom's story
and his reality so Goodman was studying
at Oxford when he overheard a legend of
a random genius named Victor who lived
from his reality into our reality and no
one had ever heard of him before and and
so he took over Oxford labs and briefly
used them for his research so I think
how this is going to introduce in a
post-credits scenes from spider-man 3
kutiman is gonna be back in Oxford
working on something researching writing
a paper and all of a sudden you're going
to see that hood that we talked about
before walking through the door kudamon
is gonna be attacked by Victor Von Doom
and he's gonna say something catchy
along the lines of you stole my story
goo termen and now your reality is
doomed and he's played by he's played by
vincent cassell from the most recent
season of Westworld
because he's got that kind of accent I
know he's friend he could be a Latvian I
feel like he slept there he's a
librarian Prince you know I'm gonna go
ahead and put on his Wikipedia he is the
Prince of Liberia that's a great theory
and I love the idea of Victor Von Doom
kind of just slipping into our reality
just through the blip like everyone else
returned from where they were taken but
he just kind of like slipped in with
that blip he's like I'm here now they're
like were you here before it he's like I
was here the whole time I also loved the
Oxford setting cos like I know the Harry
Potter movies were shot Oxford they wear
robes like the old professor robes we
found some old like Oxford cleric robe
and that's like his robe this is green
it's my color oh that's great Thomas you
have started with a with ten golden
spark because you're a golden child yes
I am deducting one because of the
can't get out of my mine when you say
you stole my story I'm thinkin like a
secret window like you stole my story
yes John Turturro you stole my story
devastated to burn this gorgeous WCW
Monday nitro NWO radio adapting
microphone that used to have a
microphone had what you do is you put
used to put batteries on and turn the
radio to a certain frequency on the FM
then you turn it on and you could
actually broadcast through your radio it
also features sound effects from
Goldberg Hollywood Hogan's sting and big
sexy Kevin Nash so well this was a toy I
treasured as a 13-year old boy it's now
going in the flames boys relic not
anymore it was really sticky is moving
around in my hand it was very very
sticky but I don't know why so anyway
I'm actually glad to see it's gone I'm
glad to see it gone alright joven what's
he got first I would like to call it a
mistake I made earlier I accidentally
said that I was fully squeezed that's
weird I'm freshly squeezed that's the
correct slope I just someone's gonna
call me out for it now I want to know
that me time so myself and my sentient
mustache here are gonna actually pull
from a past argument from this show from
fellow genius and comic book historian
Jovi Shire from a past episode mr. fury
we're working in reports there's a ship
out there there's five beans on this
ship get that mother stories that he
wove 'end from nothingness that I now
consider headcanon
where we will actually have the sword
ship actually find a spaceship with five
other beans on that ship which we will
find out are actually the Fantastic Four
and
on doom wow that [ __ ] now it is so easy
to go ahead and make Victor Von Doom the
next big bad of the MCU but when it
comes to bad guys in the MCU we kind of
see it done one of two ways either you
have a villain that's in one movie and
they're very forgettable or you have a
character like Loki or Fanus where it's
really built over nine different movies
to have a good character art well in
this case we're gonna find the middle
ground
I think Marvel is now ready to really
focus some bad guys into their worlds
that just kind of stay ever-present so
Victor Von Doom shall not be the bad guy
of Fantastic Four the first movie he
shall not be the bad guy the big bad in
the MCU at the time but what is becoming
more and more popular in the superhero
world of casting agents and contracts is
you're Mark Ruffalo contract where you
not necessarily getting your one
standalone movie or your own trilogy but
you were gonna pop up in six different
movies Mark Ruffalo now Superman has the
same type of contract and when Adam
Scott plays Victor Von Doom he will have
a similar contract where he is just
ever-present he's he's there on that
first ship we find out that he is
stirred and get powers but you know he's
not at his full power yet he's not at
full ego yet and we just see him popping
up in a spider-man movie and another MCU
movie he's in all three different
Fantastic Four moves well Fantastic Four
is finding Mole Man in the first movie
he's just kind of in there building up
Latveria and everything and then at the
end of his sixth movie which will then
be fantastic for the third movie that is
when we see him really at his peak bad
guy miss with other doombots doing his
doom work and being the bad guy not just
for the Fantastic Four but the entire
MCU it's kind of like a sub boss next to
like I neglect this when he shows up or
something Eric can I can I submit what
your gripe will be yeah because that's
amazing and I love it it's just that I
will never ever take Adam Scott
seriously yeah based based on his
character from big little lies when he
was just like oh he's so good with
comedy but also has such a great acting
range and he's
most being typecast as like that
character from from Parks and Rec a
little bit I think this is moment and
that's why you don't want someone that's
too menacing in the first movie you want
someone that you just gradually hate
over time and then eventually you're
scared of that nerdy kid that learned
how to make nuclear warheads and you're
like oh we should not be making fun of
that guy um I you know I that was gonna
be my gripe with it Mirena you could
unlike that match you know you'd get it
back but it's too late you burned it but
I do like looking back Adam Scott did
play one of the best villains in in
stepbrothers fantastic
he could do that I don't know if that's
big Doubront do you know he's got a
little creative spark that he like when
he likes to de-stress he sings like
about
Tobin I I do love that you built on your
past theory something I have done before
I'm like this already took back the back
work on this one yeah just keep making
our own theories Canon head Canon this
we do I really do love this idea of
using that space station for something
and making that the sorts baby I think
the idea was the ship that Nick Fury was
on in the post-credits scene in a far
from home right like maybe that could be
what the shoot that could be the peak I
I'm hoping that's what we see but I
really do love this idea of just having
him as a character who's popping up in
different places and then build up to it
so there's not too much expectations we
already kind of know him I feel like
that's kind of what they did with Danno
saw right he was just kind of like
background a little bit and then finally
give him the movie and there is a film
there's a comic where I think it's
inspired my comic where he's at an
airport in outfit and then Victor Von
dooms walking through airport security
to get to Latveria spider-man it's like
are we supposed to fight him now are we
okay with him being here and like that's
what he should be in the MC he was like
this bad guy everyone knows he's bad
he's just kind of untouchable yes so
joven I will not be deducting any all
you get to hold on to all ten of yours
for now though yeah I guess
as we've seen I do on this show I mess
up near the end I get a little cocky
guess Robbie so help me Joe then if I
gripe at you at one point over these
next minutes you will lose all 10 so
well alright let us now move on with
some people who helped us bring this
show to life bespoke post thank you to
the smoke post forming sponsor this
episode if your mailbox is anything like
mine 90% of the time it's you know it's
lame crap it's bills and coupons bills
and coupons for the guy who just live in
my apartment for me but once a month I
have a reason to be stoked and that is
because of my box of awesome from
bespoke post this month I got the coasts
box and it came with a great summery
linen shirt I can't wait to try it has a
waterproof beach blanket next time I
leave the blue dungeon hopefully soon
I'm gonna look and feel great thanks to
a smoke post oh they send guys only the
best stuff every month and no matter
what you're into box of awesome has you
covered from style and grooming goods to
bar we're cooking tools outdoor gear box
opossum has carefully built collections
for every part of your life they've got
a new box called Terra that comes with
this really cool Japanese utility knife
all natural soap a bird collar
I wanted to summon a bird to do my
bidding you guys know I love birds yes I
wish I was a bird if I could be Tobias
from Animorphs who just was an outlet
who stays in a bird body for the rest of
his life
yeah you don't have to give me morphine
abilities as a bird Ellimist I'll just
stay as a bird and I went off on a
tangent there anyway to get started take
the quiz at box of awesome calm your
answers will help them pick the right
box of awesome for you they release new
boxes every month across a ton of
different categories it's free to sign
up and you could skip a month or cancel
anytime
each box costs only 45 bucks but it has
over $70 worth of gear inside you can
get 20% off your first monthly box when
you sign up at fox of awesome calm and
under the code rogue at checkout that's
box of awesome calm use the code rogue
for 20% off you
first box whoo hey Eric how long how
long do Falcons live like 15 years I
don't know I always thought that was
really bad decision-making by Tobias but
he was gonna spend the rest of his life
which is now cut in 1/4 to be a falcon
but I guess some people 20 years 20
years so yeah so he was gonna live to be
32
well if unless unless he morphed into a
12 year old Falcon in which case he's
got two Olympics left a summer games and
another summer games maybe four if you
do the Winter Games as well but we don't
know in this kovat atmosphere when we're
gonna have Olympics again that's just
wasted time by Tobias speaking of waste
of time this has been a minute wasted by
Tommy Tommy you're you're exactly right
they all should have morphed into
Galapagos Island tour yeah lived for 200
years
idiot no York is gonna take over the
brain of a Galapagos Island tortoise
mm-hmm
you could just let time wash by and then
you morph back into an elephant and then
you remember everything yes we also want
to thank another good friend who
sponsored this episode manscaped oh you
guys know how I feel about manscaped
yeah my heart
yes manscaped offers precision
engineered tools for you family jewels
they spent 18 months designing the lawn
mower 3.0 oh my god the greatest ball
hair trimmer the world has ever seen
it's waterproof there's a 90 minute
battery
it even has this LED light so you can
see what you're doing down there because
normally I have to wear one of those
coal miner hat keeps slipping off yep
that canary is dead I don't know but
it's not coming back anyway manscaping
accidents are a thing of the past thanks
to man escapes skin-safe technology they
also got a quiet stroke quiet quiet
stroke technology on their 7000 rpm
trimmer motor I can't say rpm without
sounding like I'm in a car comer
as an or p.m. on your cradle that runs
on I don't know why speed speed is
nothing to brag about when it's coming
to it grooming is in play like I don't
mind if it has to our PM's as long as it
doesn't hurt anything I know for me I
need I need the speed I don't have much
time I do these on my drive to work not
safe Miska doesn't recommend you do that
but I they help you get in and out in a
nick of time but you're not going in
with the code rogue theory whoa and
manscaped calm that's 20% off and free
shipping at manscape calm use the code
rogue theory thanks again to me
unscathed yeah
eighteen months eighteen months to build
that that's three-eighths of the waiting
time to an olympics alright every week
we play a game of broke theory with our
patrons on the new rock stars discord
server this week we had some patrons
pitched the plot of the upcoming into
the spider-verse to crack jackal had a
really great theory that I loved with
Kraven hunting down each of the
different spider things in their
respective universes that sounds awesome
and it what a setup the inheritor energy
vampires for the third movie but the
winner was Alex j13 who had a plot
theory centered around spider-man 2099
and alchemax 29 and that's like the
company alchemax being the key to it all
using the multiverse to create an army
of super soldiers which if you had that
ability to do if you're a company you're
gonna find a way to profit so some
interesting commentary there and I
really want to see I will see both these
movies but they got like stay on the
edge what do you guys think of that idea
that's great I'm always a supporter of
social comments
you said my favorite words energy
vampires I know that was cracker jackers
or Jack crackers or whichever but I
liked both theories name is crack
jackals sorry correct Jack and Buddy
whistles and I'll be honest buddy we're
praying for you but I think the second
theory was it's really incredible I like
anything that happens in 2099 not an
Olympic year I would like to mention
because it is an odd-numbered year but
if we do have Olympics then we will be
looking forward to an Olympics the
following year in the year 2100 okay all
right folks you can play - you can have
your Theory read on an episode of rogue
theory I got a dude to join our discord
has become a patron of new rock stars at
patreon.com slash new rock stars all
right let's move on to our second topic
production is set to restart soon on
some movies that we're really excited
about like the Batman matrix for
shang-chi Jurassic world Dominion tell
me for these movies it's gonna be real
difficult because of new social
distancing and safety precautions
there's like a very long 40 page list of
rules in the UK that they have to abide
by so I'm curious assuming that some of
these movies might have to adjust their
plots to accommodating these new filming
restrictions I want you guys to pitch me
on how an upcoming movie that you're
excited about might have to be changed
for safety reasons oh I got one I my
changes are all around the film I am
looking the most forward to which is
Indiana Jones 5 because we have to
acknowledge that before exists Raiders
of the Lost Ark was not called Indiana
Jones : Raiders of the Lost Ark anyway
not to explain titles to you as
fascinating as that would be I think
that let's talk about some of the main
players we have left in the IG see you
Indiana Jones Cinematic Universe we've
got Harrison Ford he's a hundred and
seven years old we've got Karen Allen
she just turned 98 and we've got
Jonathan rhys-davies
he
to my knowledge timeless he is thought
to be immortal but it's definitely over
the age of 65 and I think that when you
have players like that involved you got
to be smart we - what do we know from
from from the from covert nineteen
people over the age of 65 are in the
high-risk group so I think we have to
pivot away from whatever this script was
for Indiana Jones five and it's gonna
become something a little more in Soleri
it's gonna be we're gonna have those
characters a little more isolated what
how I think they're gonna do that is I
think they're gonna have those three
characters play versions of themselves
throughout time so the same technology
that samuel l.jackson used in Captain
Marvel and that we've seen in a bunch of
other movies recently the kind of know
the Irishman you know where you get
zombie Robert De Niro who some for some
reason walks like he's 88 when he's 30
years old like well we'll be getting a
lot of that and I think it's centered
around another actor from the first
movie coming back to play a twin brother
of his doomed character and that is
Alfred Molina playing the brother of
failed archaeological assistant Satipo
who betrayed Indiana Jones at the
beginning of the film I think he's going
to come back just for fun because I want
Alfred Molina to be in the movie and set
forward a generational decades-long
treasure hunt between the three main
characters that are still alive and I
also think we're gonna have another old
friend returning uh although only vo and
what will probably be one of his final
purposes on film I think they're gonna
get Sean Connery to record a voiceover
for this I really well I don't think
they'll get him to appear on camera I
mean he's like 92 years old I don't
think he wants to do that but I would be
surprised for you right yes he's 17
years he's 15 years younger than before
I don't know why I went legitimate age
for Sean Connery but uh I think that
Indiana Jones just gonna have to make
the movie whereas the temptation I think
would be to blow the world out and take
the burden off of Harrison Ford I think
karenallen are going to have to shoulder
a lot of the heavy lifting on this film
I think it's gonna be basically those
two and maybe another person and then a
lot of CGI danger around them Tommy I'm
afraid I will have to deduct three
Sparkle o bucks
oh you're lucky it's not more to suggest
or two to say the ages of these reveal
that Jonathan Rhys Davies is immortal
ya know how much crap he's gonna have to
go through now yeah I also I'm not sure
but I think that that character might be
problematic now because I think he's a
British man playing like a Moroccan man
so I don't know that that character
flies anyway I readily give up three
childhood this Ghostbusters thing that
you pull a ripcord from and he zooms
across he wears sneakers I've got a
ticket to the final Rochester Red Wings
baseball game at silver Stadium which
was actually two years in a row because
they couldn't get permits to build
frontier field so this guy's you with
you both of the last year right now so
this one's gone everybody's dream an
autograph
Cecil Fielder Detroit Tigers Jersey just
wrap Buffalo baby I've got two cities on
my body Detroit not from there but do I
have a tattoo of it on my body you
better believe I do
and that's another site when I call
tattoo time with Tommy they'll let you
put anything on their body so I'm taking
away another Sparkle book from you we're
gonna restructure the show not a spot a
screener of the movie bombshell guys you
don't know how many improv shows I've
done with Tommy that have slid right
into home of doing Detroit Tigers bits
for 15 minutes crowd goes crazy and I'm
like I can't get a word in I don't know
any the answer is what one was too many
and there's been way more than one
okay all right wonderful who is next
how is some movie gonna have to change
its plot due to new safety restrictions
if I may I don't believe all change is
bad and I think that there are some
franchises that kind of need a reset and
they're going to be able to take this
moment to go in a different direction
and I am looking at Jurassic world 5
Jurassic Jurassic 5 j 5 which is now
dressed world Dominion and in this
particular movie right where is it 6
it's not 6 Jurassic Park this is yeah
yes a six pack this is the J 6 pack
right now Jurassic dominion JD okay no
more nicknames let's move it oh we've
got it I enjoyed Jurassic world the one
after it was an airplane movie but with
this with the fact that we can't have a
lot of people on set oh man we got to
bring things back that's a chance to
relook at the franchise and kind of go
in a different direction I'm thinking a
survival horror now you might think
that's a weird direction to go for
dinosaurs in Jurassic Park but let's go
back a little trip down to the 90s
PlayStation 1 classic Dino Crisis make
dinosaurs very very scary I just got the
finger guns from so what I want to see
is the whole thing just kind of get
scrapped let's go back maybe you have
two or three scientists on one of the
islands now these are genetically
modified dinosaurs maybe there's
something maybe there was something
missed over time now there's a mutation
in the dinosaur genes and I'm not saying
about mutation to create a brand new
dinosaur that doesn't exist no no more
that we didn't want the first time we
don't need this time but now the
dinosaurs are just becoming more
aggressive and maybe trying to find food
sources that aren't their natural food
source for example maybe a triceratops
or a Stegosaurus are actually now
hunting and attacking
humans that doesn't have to be a process
in the whole movie but at least one
scene where maybe they're working on one
of the Sega sword and let's take a sore
eye and then it just gets really angry
and then we could have to deal with like
them like trampling through a scene
where they're trying to run away from
Triceratops and then you also have your
big bad t-rex that's now like super
aggressive more so than before and I'm
kind of looking at this like predator
meets Jurassic Park where you have one
apex predator and one person that's
trying to survive maybe get off the
island but there's one Velociraptor or
one t-rex that it's like maybe making it
to the end of the movie and he's just
trying to get off the island he has to
beat the t-rex somehow and so it takes
out all that other weird stuff that
we've been getting in Jurassic Park
movies it's getting rid of all the like
the the redos that we're kind of seeing
where it's just like the same thing over
again and we're seeing a new movie and a
new genre of dinosaurs and that's what
the people want my friends yeah I know
Sora's
interesting theory joven but you haven't
raged me because I will be taken away
300 bucks races because as much as
people love the dinosaurs I think the
three things people are looking forward
to in this next movie are named Laura
Dern Sam Neill and Jeff Eagle blue faces
we can't have a hundred and seven year
old hair support we need to it it
doesn't matter if it exposes the three
of them to danger I want them in my
dynasty well I shall take this moment to
destroy something that desperately needs
to be destroyed
is this USB of this gamestop USB with
every single one of my myspace boat
we're talking emo Dane we're talking to
steampunk party news oh this is pardon
him no the world needs this
[Laughter]
[Music]
we see those again all right all right
well marina you are now our point leader
I think I am but not for long my answer
is very stupid so so it's all my
pictures for the Batman okay and in
order to avoid Robert Pattinson having
to have many combat scenes and you know
close-up scenes he's not gonna be
fighting crime in in the traditional
sense he's gonna be a detective and he's
gonna be like finding Clues on his own
so he's like alone and it just most
mostly Clou gathering but also um one of
the things that he likes to do that this
character likes to do is because this is
from real life is like discover new
kinds of food so mostly he's just like
microwaving things and like doing really
crazy [ __ ] and you guys know about this
story about Robert Pattinson and in the
microwave mm-hmm what oh my god there's
a there's a journalist who interviewed
Robert Pattinson and like he he was like
do you want like some food or whatever
it he was like I don't know oh yeah it's
like microwaved like I can't even
remember what he put foil in a microwave
and it like exploded and was on fire
yeah and anyway my whole bit is a
reference to that like the whatever just
is
so okay but if it is a regular Batman
movie his mask is flipped so that the
bottom half is come
where's the best and then his top part
is open but you can have scenes with
whoever he wants because he already had
like pictures of him taking its bottom
people gonna like Truman Jones face back
together did I say I was gonna be the
point leader for long ago I didn't I
don't know I got no problems with this
one well marina I will be taking one two
four five because there's uh my Batman
knows how technology works he would not
get confused by how a microwave is
designed because we saw in uh it's your
one and in Batman Begins he uses you
know he knows how a microwave works to
foil the League of Shadows from
microwaving the water mains and
spreading vapor across the Narrows so
you know our Batman knows how microwave
technology works so you lose five on
that one five but okay right Batman does
but Robert Pattinson doesn't you don't
have to light five matches that's all we
know but we like to see fire right no
that's too dangerous I'm like sitting on
my bed alright our point totals are
marina has four left
Tommy has five left and joven has how do
you have seven all right
oh well all can change in our final
round of row good question alright
question number one after the ps5 design
was unveiled this week
KFC tweeted a commercial for a joke
gaming console called the Kay
console that has a hidden chicken
compartment whatever fast-food should
have a gaming console and what should it
be cool well I don't know if you guys
knew this as the video game expert in
the room I knew this but Microsoft is
actually buying out jag new box Oh so I
may be getting the the Jack in the Xbox
that's great
I actually what does it it's happening
does it serve like tacos only after - I
know mine is also an early early morning
creation a few years ago I was
approached by a Japanese video game
powerhouse Sega to create something as a
brand tie-in for McDonald's breakfast
and they're popular consoles so I
created the Sega Genesis which is a
which is a Sega Genesis that serves up
warm Egg McMuffins and then the
controllers are actually full of
capri-sun that you can sip out of it's
called the Sega Genesis Sega Genesis
Sega Genesis you guys know how sometimes
there's a combination Pizza Hut top oh
yeah mm-hmm
this is a combination dance dance Taco
Bell so it's a dance dance revelution
machine but when you pass a level it
dispenses a taco that you eat and then
you have to stop when you start [ __ ]
your brain only the bravest survive that
game yeah I mean I love to talk about
but let's go oh yeah yeah you're in the
middle of butterfly god I've been there
yep a couple adventure landings in
Jackson Florida I can't go back Oh Jay
bill alright next question okay
Meo recently added a zoom feature where
you can pay to ten minutes of zoom with
celebrities like Sean Astin Jonathan
Ramos and Brett Favre what celeb would
you most want to do a zoom with and what
would you make them do on the zoom
I would assume Rihanna and she would
show me everything in her class I would
I would zoom Rihanna and request a
completely different experience karaoke
Taco Bell
I would like Patrick Stewart just for
like my 2 a.m. zoom calls where I just
want him to count sheep for me as I fall
asleep yeah that is I might mine would
be Vin Diesel in character as Groot and
it's great no then stop saying other
things that are no no no this only works
for me if you stay in character is Groot
I lost it again stay in character is
Groot alright lastly it was announced
this week that the Oscars will be
delayed I want you to give me your best
Oscar acceptance speech for best VFX as
the result of having to make kovat
related changes to your building okay
I'll go I'm Robert Pattinson I'm sorry
about the microwave yes like a lot of
people told me dinosaurs with masks on
wasn't gonna play
they said the dinosaurs they have
different kinds of immune systems but I
said the dinosaurs are the protagonists
of this film therefore children will be
looking up to the dinosaurs therefore
the dinosaurs need to be compliant with
a proper infectious disease prevention
plan the dinosaurs must social distance
the dinosaurs must shelter in place the
dinosaurs must wear masks the dinosaurs
must not go outside if they're
immunocompromised or been in contact
anyone who tested positive with kovin in
the last two weeks people said I was
crazy I was fired from this film and yet
I'm here today because I broke out of
jail because I acquired a samurai sword
because I got America is a great country
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]
that he scares that Jake Gyllenhaal goes
Jake's why did it have to be Jake's the
point totals have not changed as the
winner
what is your a wish or my wish is you
guys have to reenact some of your
favorite movie lines as those actors but
if they were still doing those roles
today so you're a hundred and seven year
old Harrison Ford you're yes they're
very old it's your favorite movie lines
recreated my mine is the same because he
was a hundred and four when he filmed it
which is from blade and he goes some
[ __ ] always trying to ice skate
uphill but it's not blade it's what is
his name Kris Kristofferson yeah
yeah he like was a hundred Whistler yes
- Indiana was the dog's name Henry
George Henry Jones jr. and Deana let it
go I'll do one Clint Eastwood from that
racist movie if he was a hunter for a
result he would say I get off my lawn
because that's like thirty years young I
got my lottery no no we all saw this
episode of rogue theory thank you so
much - I guess marina Mastro's is wavy
and Tommy and our freshly and fully
squeezed who we also want to give a
quick update so that everyone knows
Phillip decided last week that he's
gonna be taking a little break from
being on screen just for a little while
of episodes of rogue theory a big
question he's gonna be focusing on some
big personal projects he's still very
much involved in everything day to day
at new rock stars did he just finally
collapse under his own muscle mass he
had me honest he's still very powerful
he can fire all over that's true he will
be back on camera don't worry in the
meantime you can find him on his social
media we're all very excited for this
right now he's still involved because he
just subbed tweets that's right oh yes
every tweet is about us so we love you
Phillip please don't fire us and we look
forward to have you back when you're
ready miss you so much dad don't forget
to subscribe to rogue theory on our
podcast and wherever your podcast you
can follow us on twitter
at new rock stars you can subscribe to
new rock stars on here on YouTube you
can follow me on instagram @ EA vas see
you all next time see you later Mike
[Music]